here's an amazing story Isabel Von
Spruce is the leader of 40 Days for Life
campaign in Birmingham England
she's not a terrorist she's the opposite
she's someone who prays a lot well
earlier this month she was praying
silently outside an abortion clinic in
Birmingham she wasn't yelling or
carrying a sign or blocking the doorway
or doing anything disruptive she was
just praying praying
not to the government to God and that's
not allowed anymore so police approached
her and arrested her and charged with
violating a public space protection
order and committing quote anti-social
behavior and we're not making this up it
was caught on video here it is
uh what are you here for today uh
physically I'm just standing here okay
why do I hear of all places I know you
don't live nearby I think this is an
abortion or something you're praying I
might be playing in my head
um so I'll ask you once more will you
voluntarily come with us now to the
police station for me to ask you some
questions about today and other days
where there are allegations that you've
broken
if I've got a choice then
you're under arrest the class suspicion
of failing to comply with public space's
protection order
public spaces protection order Isabel
Von Spruce joins us tonight as well
thank you so much for coming on so the
thanks to this order is designed the law
is designed to protect public spaces
from praying
well
give him a bit of background to this so
for 20 years around that I've been going
outside abortion centers and praying
there and offering help to women I know
you know well over 100 women have
accepted our help and
um continued their pregnancies
um
September this year the local Council in
Birmingham brought in this censorship
Zone this pspn
um formerly these were used for dog
fouling and drunken behavior and things
like that but they're now popping up
around the country
um surrounding abortion sentences and
they ban Behavior like protesting
um but it also names prayer and
counseling as forms of protesting
and so four times I went and stood near
the closed Abortion Center and silently
prayed there and as you can see the
police came and asked me if I was
protesting
which I wasn't they asked me if I was
praying and I said I might be silently
praying
um I was arrested I was searched I was
locked in a Cell I was then interviewed
or interrogated however you'd like to
see it
um during which I was quizzed about what
I was praying about
um I was then released on bail and then
subsequently charged on four counts of
protesting and engaging in an act
intimidating of service users
um so I now stand on on trial on
February the second supported by ADF UK
um really for freedom of thought
um and the concern is here in England
that
um National buffer zones are now being
discussed so there's a possibility of
every Abortion Center in this country
having a similar Zone around it
um and obviously the implications of
that are really concerning
if you're arresting people for praying
you are committing an act of evil it's
not a close call at all there's sort of
no debate about that and I would think
that even secular people would recognize
that did anybody any prominent person
step forward to defend you
um I I have had a lot of
um people who say that a pro-choice or
that they support abortion but they've
also got concerns about this and that in
itself is is very encouraging to hear
um that it's not necessarily about
people who support abortion or don't
support abortion this is more to do with
freedom of thought here
um it's even gone further than freedom
of prayer I mean we all talk about the
the council culture and the concerns we
have about people being canceled
um you know speaking and public
um maybe public speaking engagements but
to be arresting somebody for what
they're thinking it's just going to even
a step further it's it's just it's
actually quite surreal that's the word
I'd use to describe it I mean the amount
of people who've used the word orwellian
to me to describe this likening it to
the 1984 novel
um and and it's really seemed like that
to me from start to finish and obviously
it's not over yet but it's just quite a
surreal experience
well it's evil it's an act of evil
arresting someone for praying is an act
of evil period and it just breaks your
heart to think of all the people in
charge of prime minister on down who are
standing by and allowing this to happen
and it I'm just so glad that you did
this I hope you'll continue to do it
that's a human right they can't take it
away from you and I appreciate your
telling us about it on this show Isabel
Vons Bruce thank you